ich war die erste mit einem klick auf ok
ok ok ok moment der erste mit dem gold
digger frank dittmar vitali und gold cup
rang 1 geben komme hier auf dem gold
digger crank der schon mal drei jahre
alt ist also lieber leer und du warst
nicht der erste mit dem gold digger
prank terroristen herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video er liebe leute wisst
ihr was ihr mögt wahrscheinlich musik
ich persönlich mag nicht mehr weg
gefragt mit dem man viele positive
emotionen hervorrufen kann melancholie
hervorrufen kann negative emotionen
hervorrufen kann generell eine sache die
menschen beschäftigt deswegen passt ja
eigentlich super dass leona scheer heute
am 19 februar 2017 ein song aus gebracht
hat aus diesem einen albungen das
ungefähr vor jedem video seit anbeginn
der menschheit schon beworben wird gibt
jetzt endlich mal ein song und der heißt
king of frank und dann schauen wir
verdammt bevorzugst du ja noch zwei
sachen im allgemeinen schlechtes bild
optimal gelöst
ein erstes video im hintergrund hat und
die fällt kaum oben links ist schauen ob
ich im schnitt für den heutigen wieder
gut hinbekommen haben und zweitens hat
meine kommentare was ein guter name für
dieses format wäre an denen ich die akte
und lotse werde dafür eine idee ist
einfach und vereidigt ist mir die
kommentare durch diese alten mit
klebepunkten
[Musik]
der ohne streit die wirklich durch alles
klar die hand film ab
schau mich an ich bin ziemlich mit
klaren dinge die wir am anfang erkennen
dass dieser beat aus der leon moschee wo
werbung für fame die seit anbeginn der
menschheit vor jedem leona cher video
gespielt wird und fällen ist auch
irgendwie zum thema ferien ja also er
beginnt sein video auch mit schau mich
an ich bin ich mit klaren schau mich an
ich bin ziemlich bekannt instagram
follower und twitter follower und
lehrern sehr wichtig mit der leyen hatte
sich gewisse selbst gehostet weil wenn
du hast es eigentlich so format um eine
gemacht die man eigentlich überhaupt
nicht machen möchte in seinem ganzen
leben deshalb leeren maschine sieht den
akt sein eigenes album zu bestellen auf
einer stufe mit leuten nach geld fragen
polizei verarschen nackt durch die
straßen laufen schrieb keine ahnung was
in diesem format machen aber weg zu
lehren ist die hemmschwelle sein eigenes
album zu bestellen recht groß dass auch
wichtig weil er überall ein rausch hast
du weißt du was leute ist frank eure
lehrer kommt schickt mir die nummer
schick mir den namen ich war direkt da
hin selbstverständlich macht es nicht ja
wie weit es auch letztens emi wenn ihr
das album vorgestellt kommt ein euro
schule am arsch
wie kommt man überhaupt keine schule und
empfängt doch überhaupt kein lehrer da
können wir alle bei ihm das schreiben
aber das ist eine andere sache worauf
ich hinaus will
es steht also bisher wenn ihr so
instagram bilder macht wenn ihr wollt
ihr richtig viele durch mich auf die
durch die kulisse schlafzimmer lag
ja wenn ich der lehrer franken sollte
install direkt zu dem hin
warum besteht kinderschokolade einigen
kindern die seien geplant
dass das heft das ist okay leon kann und
lieber leon reuter mich manchmal mit im
spiel
aber auch ich finde man sollte kritik
immer nur knapp verloren
deswegen machen wir das was uns gesagt
hat und wir geben deinen namen 1 bei
instagram leon masche instagram und hat
gesagt dass wir wenn mit dem namen bei
ist beim eingeben sehen dass ich im kino
franken
das checken kurz mal leon der profi okay
das stück nichts von frank was e mail an
fame punkt fan box at gmail.com es ist
nicht ernsthaft seine bitte e mail
fällen punkt fan box was soll ich sie
male der treffer nur zwei millionen
abonnenten abonji mail die wörter für
die gala okay aber ein machtwort hinter
sich in seiner besteht weil die
nenninger knopf trenker schreibt ja
nicht selbst wird schon mal hinter die
kommentare
leon bruder das war das beste lied
nieder mit apotheke hast du das lied nur
auch von ihm sucht ev hast du zufällig
aids alle in fünften mal antworten
[ __ ] du bist der beste wetter
pranken als ob banker wirklich scheiße
sagt der glückliche making-of
krankgeschrieben wahrscheinlich kam aus
diesem ein kommentar von beust den
salvenmoser salvenmoser
definitiv ich würde darin entweder man
kann hier und zeigen dass ihre
möglichkeiten offen aber danke sebastian
seiten moser du kleines zucchini
geeignet
[Musik]
okay leute was aber machen in deckung
gehen oder lang schlank er hat viele
praxen sein master plan
da habt ihr gehört meine kommentare ob
es in deckung gehen oder alarm schlagen
sollen
[Musik]
okay okay okay aufnehmen um wählen der
erste mit dem gold cup rang das mit war
auch kurz mal wegstecken
okay wir schon hat man nach leonberg
gold digga der beta test teil 2
bittstädt mit locke der bildteil drei
auto offen lassen frank okay da kommt
nicht mehr so wirklich was leggins frank
okay es gibt kein einziges video von der
mafia was die krankheit aber es gibt der
betreiber schaum auf ablaufdaten ok 27
der elfte 2014 gemacht und 720 ps 2014
und das leeren behauptet er war der
erste
im gold cup rang welt aber war vitali
und gold cup rang eingeben kommen wir
hier auf den gold-rang der schon mal
drei jahre alt es genaugenommen von 15
2013 also über ein jahr bevor leonberger
plank gemacht hat also lieber lehrer du
warst nicht der ersten mit dem gold cup
rang drei war vielleicht der erste der
ihn aus amerika kopiert hat wenn ihr
wichtig ist dann kümmern das festhalten
er war der erste der den gold-cup lang
aus amerika kopiert hat okay das auch
bei lehrern die allgemeine dinge
geblättert wird schon mal so eine art
sondern diese zu die polizei plant
gemacht und da haben auch negative bei
mir geschrieben habe schon den hat er
von logan paul aus amerika geklaut und
wenn wir damals schon sehen wir dass
logan port von dem monaten video gemacht
hat indem er sein bruder hat warten
lassen vom secret service was ungefähr
so was wie die polizei lübeck
es ist schon wieder so euer vater
fenster ich will mich ja gar nicht so
weit aus dem fenster lehnen und sagen
dass lee und alle tracks geklaut hat
auch wenn es theoretisch natürlich sein
kann er aber das will ich gar nicht aber
es scheint so als wäre die welt von der
maschine so eine in europa gibt die noch
afrika und asien
aber amerika also alles was über den
atlantik was gibt's eben nicht das ist
die einzige erklärung dafür dass gesagt
erst der erste dem politiker frank
obwohl die amerikaner den schon jahre
davor gemacht haben also dieser stelle
leon es gibt so etwas wie amerika über
dem atlantik ist noch eine landmasse da
es unter anderem aus amerika in
nordamerika die usa wo du zumindest ein
paar deiner prank ideen her bekommt und
dementsprechend sind die väter und
fenster der frank fleck leute wie vitali
aber nicht du musst das video wirklich
alle zehn sekunden stocken viele
wünschten werden so großes talent dazu
sage ich mal nix ich meine hahaha ich
weiß ich will selbst in meinem finger
und schaue mir videos von anderen leuten
alle machen darüber lustig ja ich
behaupte nicht dass ich über
talentierteste mensch bin aber ich sehe
sehr wohl wenn leute die nicht die aller
talentierten oder kreativsten sind
behaupten sie wären die qualität ist
darf mich natürlich auch darüber lustig
machen also das vergessen mal mit dem
großen talent wären okay dass plattner
kosten
[Musik]
okay okay wir können aber noch eine
sache machen wir mit insgesamt schauen
wir doch mal ein youtube kommentare leon
sagt wir sehen ihn gründen denn die
leute meeting of brancalion das schauen
wir mal kurz ion in youtube kommentare
wer ist auch nur hier zu liken nein denn
die nicht gesprengt gut spaß schlecht
auch kein kiosk auf dein album okay der
kontinent nicht scheiße wie immer wir
nennen dich klingauf lutscher schrott
und display du bist king of pop war okay
wie soll man damit umgehen also
irgendwie die user kommentaren gibt
nicht so viele die intel noch krank
nennen vielleicht müsse das mit king of
prey bedenken